Mateo I had an epiphany yesterday
I've always been a a believer in God
and spiritual I thought
but I've been watching that
what was I watching yesterday oh god
um the U.S and the Holocaust which is
the Ken Burns doctor the movie he was
telling us before Oh God on the plane on
the plane I looked over last night I
watched it he had tears in his eyes I
finished it last night right and
um it's so funny because back in the day
they had America first which was like
this movement it's the same as Maga I
think things just kind of recycled Henry
Ford was a foot yeah yeah yeah he was a
prick right and it's just the same thing
like we don't want immigrant you know
you know and it's like um
but it's you know when all you know six
million Jews and in my mind I I just I
don't know why I even never thought
about it before I'm like they're just
and you tell the Christians you know you
ask Christians you go well um how could
he allows six million people and they
was like well it's a mystery yeah it's
always a mystery I don't challenge them
but they had very hard facts about who's
going to heaven and not like let's pick
and choose you [__] psycho right yeah
God has a plan right right and I was
thinking last night I was like there's
nothing a mystery so when I die God will
reveal what the mystery is why why the
mystery there's nothing he can say
that's gonna make me go oh he goes
through all this effort to like sort of
like make us like a guess you know what
I mean yeah and what a cruel
another thing that they say there was a
time where like dinosaur bones well
Satan did that did he yes Satan Satan
planted these dinosaur bones to deceive
us
Satan I imagine
not something Skeletor and He-Man
well hey man you bumbling
yeah so lastly I just had this kind of
and it bums me out because I feel I have
a fear of death do you
I that's the one thing I don't have a
fear of is that weird you don't have a
fear of death no what's your biggest
fear no probably people saying expresso
there it is guys yeah you don't have any
fear of death no
I don't want to die in a terrible way
but being dead terrible is kind of
poetic at the same time you know like
just being like mangled
getting like a chunk of your ass taken
out by a monk seal like there is
something very poetic about going out in
a strange way yeah that's true you don't
want to just die in your sleep you don't
have any Rose from Titanic
especially with the Bobcat though I was
hiking there today we were hiking well I
was hiking the other day
there's only one reason you couldn't you
would have gone on a hike for a girl no
I was by myself what I'm
hey good reason or I'm [__] [__]
fat man good reason all right that's why
I'm a [__] high and Hiking I didn't
eat last last night
why did I we fasted together so anyway
I'm in on a trail hiking last week right
and I go and you know I go I was by
myself you know how you sometimes you
see a bunch of like producers on the
trail
yeah I'm nodding but I don't know yeah
there was no one I go is there if
there's a bobcat I'm dead but then I
realized why can't I just honestly
fetal position
right your fetal position your face is
to the ground like this and you just go
into a ball he's gonna nibble at your
back no wait a second I don't think you
realize what a bobcat looks like I think
you're talking about a mountain lion
a little bit smaller they're a little
cuter with a little things mountain lion
then yeah yeah yeah even a mountain lion
can you just feel it and he he takes
chunks out of your back I still do a
movie that's a bobcat oh they're kissing
oh those are cute why is this guy in a
ball
yeah slowly walking by like what a crazy
weird Korean oh yeah I think could still
[__] you up though what does a mountain
lion look like those are those are
cougars those are like you know Puma
size yeah mountain lion is like
California mountain lions are pretty big
they're like [__] lion oh they're
cute too though I know but we have those
up there right we do yeah yeah you'll
forget it I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead you're [__] there's nothing you
can do no there's nothing you can do
yeah you're out so Mateo good luck in
Australia thanks mate
and uh I would like to see you again yes
when I come to New York I'm gonna call
you please and um I I think you know
you're gonna be you're a big star now
but you're gonna be it's gonna be insane
man in the next five years man thanks
and um I love you bye